en parle du bâtiment et travaux publics
dansante a dit ce matin bonjour steve
fatale bonjour vous êtes le président du
syndicat des entrepreneurs en bâtiment
travaux publics et annexes de martinique
on vous a entendu hier faire une longue
démonstration sur les chiffres du
secteur 7 heures qui s'effondre et ça ne
date pas seulement d'hier plutôt
d'avant-hier et même auparavant
depuis 2007 absolument depuis je dirais
nous avons commencé à tirer la cité de
la sonnette d'alarmé depuis 2008 2008
ça n'a rien donné 2012 nous avons nous
expliquons que nous sommes dans une
position difficile et que petit à petit
nous allons aller dans l'impasse
personne n'a voulu nous quoi en 2012
nous avons fait une démonstration où on
était bien obligé de le croire puisque
nous avons donné les éléments qui
prouvait que le secteur avait des
difficultés on a lancé un plan de
relance le plan de relance parfaitement
insuffisant depuis 2015 nous l'avons
pensé que nous avons atteint la limite
mais malheureusement il se trouve que
nous sommes descendus ruban de faux airs
en plus font encore plus fond et en plus
de ça il faut savoir que ce n'est pas
uniquement quand on parle du bâtiment et
travaux publics on a l'impression que
les gens entendent maison il s'agit pas
que de ça regardez l'état des routes
regardez le nombre et je viens
d'entendre les problèmes des salles
ibilité de deux logements qui lie à
réagir et habilité ça aussi c'est le
dc100 6 et le bt 6000 personnes qui
travaillent aujourd'hui il est à peu
près sept mille deux cents personnes qui
travaillent en moyenne plus et c'est ça
qu'il faut ajouter à côté vous avez des
instrus des industries qui travaille
pour le secteur du btp
vous avez des services vous avez des
vendeurs le matériau qui travaille pour
le secteur du btp
et ça on oublie vous avez aussi une
tranche d'une trois importantes du
secteur du bâtiment ce sont des
transporteurs donc effectivement il ya
plus deux l'insee dénombre dix mille
ouais trois raisons à cette prise comme
en public en panne construction de
logements sociaux en chute libre
consommation des fonds européens
difficile et puis aussi l'exode de la
population martiniquaise lamartine et
qui perd ses habitants et ça aussi des
répercussions sur vous absolument vous
n'avez pas si vous n'avez pas de travail
qu'est ce que vous faites pour aller
chercher du travail
vous pouvez en trouver aujourd'hui la
martinique il semblerait d'après les
chiffres que nous perdons à peu près dix
mille personnes par an ok le chômage ne
cesse d'augmenter
ce qui prouve qu'il y à véritablement un
problème d'emploi
on n'a pas besoin d'être grand week end
les connaître pour s'achever le steve
pâte on la constate à nous à café des
pylônes et notamment pas les deux
observatoires du btp pour savent
exactement côté nouillers côté nous paie
à l'ipp doutant pas les deux
mobilisations antilles guyane réunion
martinique guadeloupe guyane parce que
toute la nuit même problème l'an et
jeudis jusqu'à virer à six bateaux
applaudis que personne pas grâce à ray
ban ki moon a pointé du doigt
directement d'abord tel est le cas vous
mangez d'abord à l'état cédera valley
ensuite nos gars à novak a attaqué
personne et c'est sa faute mais tenté
tueur nous n'attaquons personnes nous
sommes venus exposer un problème parce
qu'il semblerait que l'on comprenne pas
le problème et les dernières
informations que j'ai eu ne serait-ce
que ce matin sans que on a rien compris
kidari copie d'abord étant d'abord
l'état ensuite parce que l'état sa
première action puisque nous allons
avons déjà donné des éléments première
action choses aurait été de ils ont fait
un petit des petits gestes ils ont
mobilisé le hcp
mais le la ccpi là n'est pas sortie
grandie chaque fois ça le haut
commissariat la commande publique mais
qui ne se sentent si ce conflit pas
uniquement aux séries b tp un dans celle
de la santé mais je dirais de la
commande publique mais qu'elle en est on
du plan contre agen région qu'est ce qui
a été fait qu'est ce qui reste à faire
nous n'avons aucun élément nous n'avons
aucune visibilité à l'état l'étape à ras
bord les collectivités territoriales pas
ah bah ouais ce soit la septième les
communautés d'agglo les îles les
communes de martinique personnes baba
plé son peso newport accompagne brio
pour le secteur ce bateau lui faire
comprendre que bon matin aux autres
insectes car l'épisode ses alentours du
10 1024 avaya d'un les autres pas ni
moyens fait 300 tonnes mais c'est ça
c'est si le btp tout va si le btp
va pas bien avant est-ce que la ccsa
véritable problème là c'est à dire que
en clair a dit new blood chez pays et
notre force nous nous avons montré notre
force la preuve nous avons montré notre
force l'année puisque je capte toujours
nous avons montré notre force mais nous
voulons démontrer aux martiniquais que
si l'on n'est pas capable ça heures sans
violence sans pression de se mettre
autour d'une table pour pouvoir discuter
devant une situation difficile est
catastrophique
nous n'avons pas notre place et ceux qui
sont là ce sont des donneurs d'ouvragé
ils n'ont pas leur place il faudrait qu
est il faudrait qu'on leur explique
qu'est ce que c'est que négocier
discuter
malheureusement pour cette négociation
c'est que yoann volontaire depuis que yo
dix autres satellites en salle et en
sortent pas du tout pas du tout les
propositions a fait une proposition afin
de nous protéger des expertises keyyo
pas ni ne peut porter ou des constats
que peut-être que pas connaître mais
fort plus haut savent que all you s'est
occupé dix pays a économiquement
culturellement socialement tout ça où
les faux frais médicaux viola pour
mettez vous au travail alors l'état
quadruppani l'agent la 7e qu'à rappeler
sans cesse que ben hilal avait la
difficile que s'attaquer à ganges écrit
la même mais qui bien là tu es aussi
difficile bannu que ba ba la guadeloupe
balade communes et aux animaux la
guadeloupe car ici aussi les unit coolio
motivé coyot trouver l'argent
comment y aura 10 - 15 min scavini ciani
un problème de canalisation problèmes
d'eau d'assainissement
depuis combien de temps les nous montrez
nous fait louper ira les contenus ses
bouquins la dette à payer les produits à
l'étude qui a démontré que bien le
travail pouffer tout moun ka dit que
c'est pas vrai c'est une maladie puisque
l'autre 14 ni aux six autres cadres ont
dit que 65 % de l'eau qui se tient dans
les inox à peine tu es là en chine mais
alors comment il y aura dix mois que
avant-hier la semaine passée oignons
miniski vigny il trouvait 7000 et au
boulot en guadeloupe
il paraîtra en manière pour balma en
parle c'est que ici à ne pas s'appeller
basse et mini cela ne passa pas les
balles et à nous passera paribas les
collectivités ou bio passe à tous
pl - au palais tonnes a apparemment des
pme compagnie caillou balle et n ya pas
layton yoopa n'a pas abouti yopal est un
mois comprennent qu'ils ont des
difficultés sendaï cup et comprendre la
semaine passée lors des discussions sur
les orientations budgétaires à la 7è
igen la voiture
rappelez-nous et puisque c est lui qui m
a fait fort en europe et il dit que
devant la rareté des fonds peut-être que
ni atteignant notre mobilisation pour
fait pour ça gérer les fonds européens
pour y danser certains secteurs
économiques ou qu'à penser au
renouvellement de maintenance
médicaments quoi cb manque à mon cas
souhaité c'est qu'elle montre et de
l'eau compagnie café c'est tout
mais quand tu marathon nous allons faire
nous allons faire ma vie ni expliquer
nos coûts moyennant quoi faire
depuis combien d'années de radio
attendre parfaite quoique je parlais des
chantiers qui j'apprenne à être lancé
ban ou lisse et chatilla et puis banos
un planning urbat abad même steve pato
le secteur du btp caddies des pylônes et
que aux besoins en état des lieux des
chantiers de la commande publique tout
ça sera fait au moins des trois quarts
cloneur camin de saint louis mais n'ont
pas fait il nous mêmes nous coiffer en
fin de journée des éléments dits meller
moon a pas qu'à bord les éléments liés
au cac cash et éléments lego bien chez
mes éléments comme cela fut le cas chez
cet animal takashima ici oui ah ouais
j'aime la vie j'aime rire gagnant l'oms
cachalot gbagbo maintient radio radio
mon nom qui m'ont caché puisque tout
travail de transparence transparence
transparence peut être les autres
secteurs le secteur du bâtiment par de
transparence nous pas ni les éléments
nous ne bouderons s'affiche entier qui
poussent aux ti you can c'est nouveau ça
mais tout ce qui est dit et qui n'est
pas écrit ça à voir donc laurent madiot
écris-nous l'ensemble de sa qui poussent
aux ti aussi bien l'état aussi bien la
7e aussi bien la casse
aussi bien les communes une idée du
chantier kibuchi tout m'a dit ah ouais
mais ils ont pas les moyens pour pouvoir
mettre en place le générique pour
pouvoir est bien là
et ah là là c'était un passage des eaux
mais ma foi proposition m'a dit c'était
comme une ligne à l'eau t-bag avez vous
fait une rentrée la chaîne magnitude ces
réparations l'école à tout ça non en ce
jeudi des propositions comme le para
sismiques a parlé de l'assainissement de
la connexion des zones au parquet que
sont cp fait wimy à l'aube à l'autre
avec un oubli comme ancien député
certainement d'être avec qui j'avais
quatorze des mouvements ces non dits
sûrs qu'elle ait commencé au régis fini
mais pas qu'un épisode qui fait dans le
sud et pis de loi
oui parce que dans le sud sans problèmes
particuliers ou est très bien c'est que
ces bons ajustements n'aura pas lady
mobilisation des fonds qui nous fera
découvrir aux dix ans que si au pape s
est rompu cela c'est parce que
s'acquitter en charge de l'eau et de
l'assainissement pas fait les deux mains
pour récupérer la jungle à la jaille et
s'aggravent s'aggrave
ces politiques là globalement il n'y
avait ces bêtes là non finalement steve
peters finalement de tout bois guitare
c'est parce que nous passe a failli tout
simplement en nous collectif non nous a
fait problème non c'est qu'elle nous pas
comprendre c'est laid ou pas et piment
au contenu c'est à dire que mon bac à
comprendre que nous plaignons
contradictions problème nous c'est ça
dès le matin si nous décider et c'est ça
nous rassure et et notamment des les
maîtres d'ouvragé publics privés toutes
nos nouveautés que nous là nous paraît
faible en bessin grand mais ça finit
mettez qu'on nous l'a nommé safin ils
font tous savent que sectaire l'état
dubitative la balle et se brouilla clair
et net il ya des lieux où tu as
confiance de presse n'était surpris
d'inviter des organisations vite il est
présenté comme l'autre vit toutes ces
organisations présentes et call you you
tout
donc c'est et s'ouvrit à dix concerts à
chengdu et method man of you came et en
n 9
si nous pas les sorties dans la
situation nous guérir stefano le
président du syndicat des entrepreneurs
en bâtiment travaux publics m s de
martinique était dans son caddie bonne
journée merci